empecemos por hablar sobre cómo los he
marx o este armamento de alta precisión
precisión está cambiando el balance de
la guerra
sí mire yo creo que es importante
entender que este tipo de sistemas
tienen tres ventajas grandes la primera
es su precisión como usted ha señalado
la segunda es su movilidad que les hace
menos vulnerables hace más difícil
localizarlos y destruirlos y la tercera
la alcance los
y tú tiene un alcance de unos 85 km eso
les permite golpear blancos al interior
de la retaguardia de rusia y eso es muy
importante porque los rusos están
utilizando grandes cantidades de
artillería sin precisión ninguna lo cual
demanda un uso intensivo de municiones
en consecuencia tienen que construir
grandes depósitos de municiones cerca de
la línea de frente y eso es el tipo de
blancos que está tratando de destruir
están tratando de destruir con los he
max es decir golpear los lugares donde
rusia acumula la munición para su
artillería para destruir la cadena
logística de los bombardeos rusos y
hacer que estos bombardeos estos
bombardeos frenen en consecuencia eso es
lo que está haciendo es balancear de
alguna manera
las fuerzas entre los dos lados en
combate porque la artillería rusa que
hasta ahora contaba con una ventaja
inmensa se queda sin acceder a
suficientes municiones para mantener el
bombardeo sistemático en el que ha
basado su ofensiva hasta ahora y
cuenteros cómo ha respondido rusia que
tiene planeado vladimir putin para
atacar estos misiles de alta precisión
mire
probablemente con muchos oyentes abraham
hace poco se ha llegado aún a rusia ha
llegado a un acuerdo con irán para
comprar una enorme cantidad de drones de
aviones no tripulados cuya función
fundamental es el reconocimiento la
vulnera la vulnerabilidad de los gamers
que tiene ucrania ahora es con un número
muy pequeño
eeuu ha dado 12 sistemas y el reino
unido va a dar 3 y alemania- otros 3 en
lo que quiere hacer rusia con el
software es que le va a proporcionar
ira es localizar dónde están esos
sistemas y destruirlos si puede
conseguir eso en la medida en que son
pocos sistemas de nuevo va a ganar la
ventaja porque los sucreños van a perder
esta capacidad
e importante que han adquirido pero eso
está por ver si es posible en la medida
en que los drones los aviones no
tripulados iraníes no son de una gran
calidad y los sensores que llevan tan
poco en consecuencia hay que ver si esa
estratagema de putin tiene éxito pero
ese es esa es la respuesta que está
fabricando rusia para prepara para
neutralizar los hammers que les están
haciendo tanto daño